I believe very strongly that income
disparity is a huge issue in this
economy and you'll remember when I was
Treasury secretary I think it shocks
some people I came in my first speech I
talked about this because some of this
was covered up at some of the structural
issues during the bubble years prior to
the crisis so I believe that's a problem
number one but number two I think the
way to solve that problem is not
pointing the pic in the finger
scapegoating Republicans scapegoating
democrats democrats keep going
Republicans people skate going in China
or Wall Street we've had demagogues
throughout the history of this country
we've had populist but what we need is
problem solvers some of those problem
solvers in the past have come from Wall
Street do you think in this environment
the jump you made from Goldman Sachs to
the Treasury Department could anyone
make the move could Lloyd Blankfein be a
Treasury secretary in this environment I
would say to you it's regrettable right
now that bankers are being demonized in
my view because I view markets and banks
and investment banks as being a noble
profession and I think in terms of the
difference they can make in terms of
helping people plan for their retirement
in terms of funding innovation and new
businesses there's nothing wrong with
pointing the fingers at the banks and
and really making a huge effort to clean
things up correct the practices but the
problem is if it just ends there if all
you do is say it's the bank's fault it's
not the policymakers in Washington the
created fannie or freddie and and still
haven't dealt with it give me a break so
again i'm tired of the finger-pointing i
just want to see people working together
Democrats and Republicans working
together to restore our competiveness so
our issues art economic issues their
political issues final question for
do you see a 2016 presidential candidate
announced her otherwise who meets your
test I'm sure there are a number of them
I I i happen to be a Jeb Bush fan
because I see him as a problem solver I
see him as someone who excelled as a
governor someone I think we'll have the
programs to get the economy growing and
it's not divisive I like where he is on
immigration I looked like the fact that
he's authentic enough that then he
hasn't said well you know I used to be
for the for the for the for the Common
Core in education but but now I've
changed and so we have a process where
we I think it's an important time we
need a real leader to emerge it was
going to bring our country together and
do some of the things that need to get
done